alors on va passer maintenant au saas
des bikes triste anniversaire vous le
savez c'était il ya quatre ans jour pour
jour a été perpétré l'attentât de
l'hyper cacher porte de vincennes
c'était le 9 janvier 2015 amedi
coulibaly prend en otage les clients de
la supérette quatre personnes ont perdu
la vie et des dizaines ont été blessées
au pense à toutes les familles encore
des victimes ce soir huit mois plus tard
le 21 août 2015 à l'attentât déjoué dans
le thalys
amsterdam paris on a retracé ces
événements qui ont marqué l'esprit des
français à jamais et ce soir vous voulez
savoir que sont devenus les roues de ces
deux moments voilà c'est triste moment
et on aura avec nous la sana baky qui
sera avec nous voilà qui a été un voilà
un héros incroyable et on aura marque
mogalia nuit qui va inquiéter le héros
du thalys il ya même eu un film derrière
voilà qui a été fait regardez petit
récapitule pour la 4 ans que la france a
traversé l'une des périodes les plus
difficiles de son histoire récente
en 2015 les attentats contre la
rédaction du journal satirique charlie
hebdo le 7 janvier annoncé le premier
drame d'une année noire pour les
français c'est jour pour jour
aujourd'hui que la prise d'otage de
l'éclair cacher a eu lieu quelques mois
seulement avant la sphère du thalys puis
les attentats du bataclan mais dans ces
difficiles moments de nombreux citoyens
se sont montrés exemplaires et héroïque
le 9 janvier 2015 des terroristes
prennent en otage des clients et des
employés d'un supermarché cacher de la
porte de vincennes à paris
lassana bâti les employés de
l'établissement réussi à rapatrier 17
pages dans la chambre froide
ils réussissent à s'exfiltrer par la
sortie de secours grâce aux précieuses
indications de lassana pour son acte de
bravoure le jeune homme d'origine
malienne a été naturalisé en 2015 le 27
août 2015 c'est un train thalys qui
relie bruxelles à paris qui est victime
d'un attentat
en fin d'après-midi un terroriste
s'introduit dans le train et menace les
passagers avec une kalachnikov un
pistolet 9 mm et un cutter
alors que damien jeune passager de 28
ans saute sur l'assaillant pour tenter
de l'arrêter
marco gayan parvient à arracher l'armé
du terrorisme un acte héroïque de la
part de cet enseignant franco américain
alors que sont devenus les héros des
attentats alors merci d'être là merci
lassana
merci maman merci à la mer alors là ça
n'a cherché très heureux de vous
recevoir tous les deux vous êtes donc
vous le héros de l'hyper cacher donc de
la porte de vincennes ya quatre ans jour
pour jour 9 janvier 2015 vous trouviez
dans l'hyper cacher vous y travaillez
comme comme employés vers 13 heures vous
étiez donc au sous-sol du magasin moment
de l'arrivée d'un médite coulibaly on va
revoir ces images va revoir l'entrée du
terroriste et c'est vrai qu'on a envie
de savoir vous maintenant
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes est ce
que vous avez toujours ces images en
tête et c'est vrai que vous êtes un
héros
et aujourd'hui c'est avec beaucoup de
personnes vous doivent la vie et je leur
ai dit voilà on a envie de savoir
aujourd'hui comment ça tu vis au jour le
jour et comment voilà ce qui a changé
dans votre vie est ce que vous n'êtes
pas aussi traumatisé par tous à regarder
il se rend porte de vincennes
l'hyper cacher va fermer les derniers
clients sont à la caisse l'attak est
filmée par la vidéosurveillance du
magasin
[Musique]
coulibaly vient d'abattre froidement
trois personnes un employés et deux
clients qui tentaient de fuir
il tuera une quatrième personne quelques
minutes plus tard alors là ça là vous
avez guide au sous sol plusieurs clients
inverse une chambre froide pouvant se
fermer de l'intérieur aidant à cacher un
groupe de six personnes dont un bébé
d'autres otages bien sûr n'ont pas eu
cette chance et on s'est retrouvés morts
alors vous avez sorti un livre on devine
en 2016 et unis je ne suis pas un héros
parce que vous avez toujours refusé
d'être traités comme tels pourquoi oui
depuis début mai il avait dit qu'il
avait fait si le foetus est un acte
naturel d'un acte citoyen bon pour moi
c'est pas cet acte des héros pour ça
parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous
on était tous victimes
les src - pour une poste forte tous
vivent mais voilà heureusement qu'il ya
certains qui sont en crise et
malheureusement ils n'ont pas eu la sas
mais pour moi il ne comporte pas
commencé comme un héros pour ça ces
effets du cénacle j'allais tout de suite
compris ce qui se passait dans le
magasin début j'ai pas compris parce que
quand elle est heureuse il arrive et moi
c'était aux réserves en bas d'accord
quand il a tiré deux fois à moi je crois
que c'est un et un accident vers
périphériques comme les mac mais les
magazines et verrait périphériques bon
il a répété d'une deuxième trois hommes
forts du bon je me suis arrêté pour
savoir qu'est ce qui se passe c'est à
ces moments qui est dévoyée tous les
clients que mouassa à descendre par
l'escalier il disait que les terroristes
sont rentrés même ça s'est pas créé
parce qu'il est comme les mandats des
îles étaient déserts et braqué pendant
des an avant qui avant que moi europe
moi j'arrive dans les magasins se
demander est-ce que c'est pas ni
braquage d'un marquage braqueur est
demandé c'est un braquage alors vous
comment vous avez vécu donc c'est cette
prise d'otages et à quel moment vous
vous êtes dit voilà il faut que faut que
je sauve des gens vous avez pensé aux
autres parce que vous auriez pu très
bien vu voilà vous enfermer seul qu'est
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là bon
moi c'est que les moments quand même que
j'ai eu le courage de faire ça c'est la
réaction des personnes comme ils sont
derrière moi ces escaliers qui écolo
maçon il ya une personne qui paie des
100 mais avec des pc 20 personnes qui
s'est bousculé pour descendre à d'accord
s'ils avaient rien à fond aussi qui
étaient là qui avait pris tout était un
coup d'envoi ça pleurait à 40
bon faut faire quelque chose et tu es ce
que vous avez encore des contacts avec
ces ces personnes que vous avez sauvé
ouais j'avais de contacter mais comme il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
rentrés en israël
bon cela contacter par facebook comme ça
ou s'il ya des commémorations comme moi
heureux de vous y rencontrer
certaines mesures sont juste là ça
aujourd'hui est ce que vous vous voyez
toujours ces images dans le texte que
vous arrivez à vivre normalement
aujourd'hui à se dire c'est à dire
vraiment c'est dur grâce aux skis et qui
nous arrivait d'un d'un autre vie
séparent du tout facile avec les temps
oui ça ira mais vous vivez avec ça tout
le temps être tout le temps - là ça va
mieux parce que après les attentats de
2002 mois de novembre ça avec moi c'est
parce qu'il ya dans le transport moi
j'ai toujours pris tout de même devant
devant la porte parce qu'ils étaient un
peu traumatisés être bien sûr vous êtes
acquitté
même si je vois les gens qui rentrent
aux yeux vous regardent bizarrement pour
servir pour voir les réactions quoi mais
vous travaillez toujours là bas où vous
avez eu besoin de changer de lieu vous
avez pas pu rester sur place
non ce sens dès maintenant et travaille
à la vue de paris où lassana à la mairie
à la mairie de paris
alan à l'amérique par là ça n'a juste
est-ce que moi le moi c'est vrai qu'il
ya une question qu'on se pose tous
est-ce que vous avez un regret ou un
truc vous ai dit j'aurais peut-être dû
faire si j'aurais peut-être dû faire ça
j'aurais peut-être pu faire plus est ce
que vous êtes déjà dit sadr était ce
leur grain qu'est ce qui est passé parce
que à certaines personnes comment et où
avoir décidé bon on n'a pas pu le
convaincre le teigneux témoin de la
hausse pourquoi parce qu ils série étant
dit il est monté vous auriez mais le
combat ne donne pas de ne pas remonter
là où voilà on essaie de convaincre mais
il est monté mais il n'était pas selon
elle était avec mon directeur à 2 ans et
qui était monté là haut mais lui la
règle mais comme il nous l'avait tenté
arras et larmes des touristes bon il n'a
pas pu la mettre d'accord alors
franchement si vous avez des questions à
poser est ce qu'on vous a proposé
justement a suivi psychologique pour
pouvoir dépasser un peu ça et vivre
lepage pratiquement normalement on va
dire ouais j'ai été suivis pendant
presque
des mois et des mois après des mois sont
rentrés au pays parce que c'était
tellement difficile après médiatique
invitation c'était compliqué bon même
pas quelques jours après j'ai perdu mon
petit frère qui avait 19 ans c'était que
c'était compliqué mais pour moi ma mère
c'est à dire point elles vont soubise et
de rentrer quoi pour qu'il me voit quand
même de ce qui s'est passé parce que l à
perdre et on a un fils et a un fils
aussi qui est sorti comme ça bon je me
disais qu'ils sont obligatoires que ce
soit là à côté d'elle pour nicolas
physiquement pour la convaincre mais
aussi parce que ça a pris ma
naturalisation supporte plus vitaux au
moyen d'un combat merci lassana d'être
avec nous on peut applaudir marc gagnon
qui est avec nous merci d'être avec nous
soit vous êtes franco-américain
professeur à la sorbonne et vous le 21
août 2015 par ça tourne entendu parler
de cette histoire un terroriste se
prépare à commettre un attentat dans le
train thalys reliant amsterdam à paris
c'est la première fois que vous voyagez
en été vous êtes avec votre compagne et
ce jour là l'un des premiers à réagir
c'est vous ai eu marre qu'ils repéraient
cet homme avec sa grosse valise dont
l'étoile est donc qu'elle sait pas si
vous êtes tranquillement dans le train
et là vous voyez une personne qui va
avec sa valise great white est là qu est
ce que vous vous dites ça me semblait
bizarre parce que les toilettes dans le
thalys pour le plupart sont très petits
que ça m'a surpris j'étais en face tu
mon épouse qui avaient le dos jusque
contre le petit vers le mieux en verre à
côté du sas
j'ai attendu peut-être une dizaine voire
une quinzaine de minutes avant de me
lever pour voir qu'est ce qui se passait
mais sans avoir pensé qu'il s'agissait
de d'un acte terroriste ou train de se
préparer et j'ouvre le sas je vois
damien le fond c'est à ma gauche penser
contre le mieux j'attends quelques
secondes
et puis la porte des toilettes souffre
et voilà le terroriste avec les gros
yeux la teste aussi assez grand et avec
un ak 47 sur l'épaule droite et
on se regardait tous et c'était comme
dans un rêve
c'était assez incroyable en plus un
frein qui montre d'amsterdam
donc tu peux arriver les gens pour y
attirer déguisée au moins on pourrait
penser ça rapidement
et puis au moment où à damien louis
avait pris par la gorge alors d'avancer
c'est le français qui a choisi de rester
anonyme c'est ça voilà c'est le premier
d'avoir mis les mains dessus lui lui
aussi il a tout de suite vu qu'il y
avait un problème avec ce passage on se
regarde et agit en fait ce qui est dur
c'est que dans bien il était là parce
que elle est allée aux toilettes dont la
voiture 13 et à l'un des agents de la
sncf lui avait dit que les toilettes
étaient condamnés donc c'est pour ça
qu'il est venu dans la voile ou alors
est il ou elle à la halle aux
terroristes or donc avec avec son ak 47
et qu'est ce qui se passe à damien louis
pompe par la gorge et tout de suite je
me suis rendu compte ce qui se passait
et j'ai fait une sorte de calcul dans ma
tête et ont donné qu'ils belle mon
épouse qui assis juste derrière le mur
je me suis dit il va avoir la bagarre
j'ai peur qu'elle va prendre une balle
perdue
donc la première chose que j'ai fait
c'était de rouvrir le sas et lui dire va
t'en c'est du sérieux
elle est partie mais finalement pas
aussi loin que j'aurais espéré et puis
moi je reviens pour donner un coup de
main d'un bien et à ce moment là il y
avait d'autres personnes qui sont
passées un agent de la saucière qui est
allé alerter conducteur du train
l'outragé la sncf qui va nous arriver à
lui arracher son arme oui oui je ne sais
pas comment ça s'est passé mais j'ai
réussi à me parler de son arme et je
pense est ok là c'est bon je vais
éloigné l'arbre du tireur
et puis je vais venir donner un coup de
main d'amiens j'ouvre le sas encore une
fois je sors je dis en anglais afghane
je pense quoi pas et métiers donc de
vous attirer dans le hall d'entrée une
balle dans l'eau prenez une balle dans
le dos oui avec une 9 mm je suis tombé
par terre je pensais que c'était fini
ben j'ai réussi à rompre entre de ciel
deux rangées de sièges à ma gauche
j'ai regardé au dessus mon épaule
et il arrivait très lentement et je
pensais que c'était fini je pouvais plus
bouger donc j'ai mis ma tête dans le
ciel j'ai fait le mort et j'attendais à
ce qu'il me même balle dans la tête
parce que j'étais sûr que c'était à ce
qui allait se passer
et puis rien et puis les petits bruits
métalliques en fait l'âme s'était
enrayée et et puis j'entends départ et
arrivant de l'autre direction et des
voix et j'ose me tourner la tête juste à
temps pour voir le corps de spencer
stone dont les airs comme superman en
train de tacler le terroriste et je me
suis dit bon c'est fini pour moi parce
que j'avais perdu beaucoup de sang mais
heureusement on n'y aura que moi et puis
je me lève la tête tout doucement il ya
un espace entre les sièges dans le
thalys est d'oranger plus loin comme
dans un miroir un autre tête se lève et
c'est mon épouse et j'étais très content
parce que je pensais que comme ça
j'aurais eu l'occasion de lui dire au
revoir de lui expliquer que déjà je suis
touché et c'est fini mais je voulais
qu'elle voit que je n'avais pas peur de
mourir que que ça va et puis spencer
alec et anthony et éventuellement crise
norman ils ont réussi à ligoter le
terroriste et puis spencer est venu me
voir il était ambulancier dans l'air
force américain et là tu simplement mais
ces deux droits dont le trou dans mon
cou pour arrêter l'hémorragie
il avait mis un doigt sur l'artère il
sentait il m'avait dit plus tard et on
est resté comme ça par terre pendant une
bonne vingtaine de minutes mais avec ses
doigts oui oui ben j'avais même pas vu
son visage
j'ai tenté de me lever parce que je vis
très mal la balle avait fait des dégâts
dont les nerfs du bras gauche et j'étais
vraiment
je souffre un peu et et puis pendant ce
temps à mon épouse isabelle elle était
elle est allée chercher les cravates
pour déjà pour ligoter le monsieur elle
est allée chercher quelque chose pour
mettre autour de mon cou en voilà et à
elle elle était allée chercher un
médecin il y en avait pas apparemment
donc elle avait fait beaucoup de choses
aussi pour s'occuper de moi
alors pour vous là vous vous êtes
persuadé vous allez mourir
oui et puis j'ai perdu conscience à un
moment donné vous savez on est parti à
amsterdam le 19 août c'est
l'anniversaire de ma mère que j'avais
perdu deux mois avant un concert de
pancréas est une chose qui était plutôt
positive c'est que quand j'ai perdu
conscience j'ai fini par le revoir dans
un rêve et je ne sais pas combien de
temps ça va durer mais c'était assez
agréable finalement mais j'ai dû
m'arracher un peu de ça pour me
réveiller
il n'y avait pas du leur alors pendant
que jean lassalle à 10 et un instant qui
vit avec ça tout le temps maintenant est
ce que c'est votre cas aussi la à oui
mais moi je vois que pour moi c'était un
jour de chance hein on a eu beaucoup de
chance hier aux vêtements vous êtes vous
êtes un rescapé vous êtes vous êtes un
miraculé on l'a c'était un travail
d'équipé on a réussi à faire ce qu'il
fallait faire et le fait que je sois là
avec vous ce soir c'est que je sois en
vis et c'est assez incroyable donc je
suis j'essaie de me focaliser là j'avais
pu reprendre une vie normale
et oui j'ai pigé oui oui j'enseigne je
fais j'ai repris les thalys plusieurs
fois depuis
je me suis obligé parce que on avait
l'habitude d'y aller régulièrement en
hiver ne voulais pas que ça que ça
s'arrête à cause de ça c'est un
incroyable comme témoignage c'est vrai
que quand on le vit là quand vous
racontez
oui moi j'aimerais c'est une question
sur les faits en eux-mêmes c'est
peut-être complètement débile mais que
puisque vous avez arraché la kalachnikov
des manu terroristes
est-ce que vous avez été tenté vous en
servir pour la battre j'ai pensé
rapidement mais vous savez
la pensée c'est super rapide dans les
moments comme ça c'est comme une fluide
et à je pensais on est il ya de métal
partout ça pourrait faire ricocher est
franchement bien bien que je sois
américain mano franco américain je
connais pas trop les ans mais j'aurais
pu faire une bêtise et ma première
réaction c'était juste éloigné l'armé du
tireur
quand on pense tous comment s'est passé
avec les autres passagers
après quand vous avez maîtrisé le
terrorisme vous êtes tous tombés dans
les bras je sais pas est ce que vous
êtes dit si c'est incroyable on a failli
tous mourir est ce que vous êtes venus
est-ce que vous avez gardé contact avec
les autres et roux socialiste qui a même
eu un film oui oui on est on a pu à
jouer nous proposons le film et j'ai vu
je joue un peu de haut et à spencer et
moi on s'appelle régulièrement on a fait
des voyages ensemble c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de très sympathique
oui et pour moi c'est le vrai héros du
thalys parce qu'il a terminé le travail
ouais ouais alors juste est-ce que les
autres passagers sont venus vous voir
après pour vous remercier pour vous
j'étais par terre et pour les autres va
possible en fait non c'était par le
moment bien sûr et heureusement des
pompiers sont venus à la gare d'arras et
j'étais très content de les voir c'est
une histoire incroyable voulais
absolument revenir sur sur ce triste
anniversaire
ce soit parce qu'on a une pensée bien
sûr pour toutes les familles des
victimes qui bien sûr elles ne
retrouveront pas ceux qu'elles ont
perdus et bien sûr qu'il doit vivre avec
ça tous les jours et pour qui c'est très
difficile car chaque anniversaire pour
elle eh ben ça doit être un moment et
une journée très très compliqué donc
voilà on voulait vous dire que s'il
avait aussi de cette personne n'avait
pas vous n'aviez pas retiré larmes ça va
être un carnage et l'heure est à le
conçois assez nombreux pour que chacun
juge sans grand bain exactement bas
merci en tout cas à marcq merci à la
samare
voir ce soir